dans son discours d'ouverture de ce
sommet des brics vladimir poutine a
évoqué la nécessité d'unir tous les
efforts afin de lutter efficacement
contre cette pandémie avec des
conséquences très concrètes la création
prochaine d'un centre de recherche sur
les vaccins commun aux cinq pays membres
à la suite d'une décision prise il ya
maintenant deux ans en afrique du sud
mais aussi la production possible du
vaccin russe spoutnik v par la chine et
par l'un et bien sûr la tâche qui
consiste à développer des mesures
collectives au sein des brics pour
lutter contre l'infection renforcer la
coopération entre les services
épidémiologiques et protéger la vie et
la santé de nos citoyens est aujourd'hui
au premier plan
je voudrais noter que le fonds russe
d'investissements directs a conclu des
accords avec ses partenaires indiens et
brésiliens sur des essais cliniques du
vaccin spoutnik v ainsi qu'avec des
sociétés pharmaceutiques en chine et en
inde sur l'ouverture de centres de
production de notre vaccin dans ces pays
et pas seulement pour leurs propres
besoins mais aussi pour des pays tiers
je pense que c'est très important des
vaccins russe existe il fonctionne ils
fonctionnent efficacement et ne
présentent pas de danger l'objectif
c'est de lancer une production de masse
sous gestion
masseret président et attend toujours
dans le cadre de la lutte contre la
copie de 19
le président russe a réitéré sa
proposition faite lors de la dernière
assemblée générale des nations unies qui
est de lever au moins temporairement les
sanctions et autres restrictions
commerciales actuellement en vigueur
l'objectif que les populations des pays
en question déjà fragilisée par ces
sanctions puissent accéder plus
facilement aux produits alimentaires
médicaments et matériel médical
dans son discours il a également été
question des mesures de relance
économique à prendre sitôt passée cette
crise sanitaire en particulier grâce à
la banque de développement communaux
cinq pays membres et forte d'un capital
de 100 milliards de dollars
on l'aura donc compris l'invention
d'ouverture de vladimir poutine a donc
été très largement marquée par le
contexte sanitaire international pour ce
sommet des brics qui se déroule pour la
première fois entièrement en visite
conférence